suit up and draw yourselves a milk bath
because it's episode three of night
fliers rabbits and space we begin with a
flashback of Carl giving a lecture to
his colleagues about an unknown
celestial object he believes to be alien
will later learn that this is the Valk
rim his colleagues however believe it's
nonsense after failing to convince them
he gets a call from captain Aris who
says they both have a mutual desire to
contact said object this is likely the
same proposal that he talked to his wife
about in Episode one and we learned that
this was all a memory down by the
airlock air stands in front of the
bodies of Dobrin in the lab tech who
were viciously murdered by the spider
robot he gives a grandiose speech about
how our bodies are simply vessels for
our spirits which when they die get
released into the universe you'll notice
it appears they're wrapped in gold it's
actually a material called multi-layer
insulation or MLI which is commonly used
on satellites to protect them from the
extreme temperatures this is likely
what's been wrapped around them so their
bodies are protected in the vastness of
space Eris confronts Carl about not
telling him about the white rabbit probe
but suddenly disappears as the bodies
are released from the airlock you can
see sucuk also survived the attack Mel
and lonely have a post sexy time talk
where we learn a bit more about lemis
past she grew up in a Luddite community
where sex and tech was forbidden but
this talk is cut short when Carl arrives
and is greeted by naked Mel and you
gotta love this guy he's got this naked
woman in front of him and doesn't even
acknowledge it anyways he wants to lomi
to track any further malfunctions so
they can get a trace on where they're
coming from Mel says in the meantime she
can try talking to eros maybe she can
get something out of him considering his
fascination with her sucuk seems to be
suffering from PTSD when Auggie hands
him a glass of brandy to calm his nerves
sucuk says the ship shouldn't be out
here well Auggie says it's the crew
that's weak this scene is yet another
indication that the writers are setting
us up for an eventual mutiny but look
who's watching is it captain eros or his
mother who may also be an AI remember
we've seen two colors on this thing red
and orange red potentially being Eris's
mother in orange being eros even in the
next scene we can see the surveillance
cam is orange markedly different than in
the previous scene melanthius presses
her concern
about what Eris is holding back asking
him to share the burden with him so
hopefully we'll find out what he's
actually been hiding so it looks like my
prediction that Tessier was only in
Thales mind was wrong since Rowan prods
her for more information about fail he's
interested in doing tests on him which
probably isn't the greatest idea but now
I'm wondering if this might be related
to how he eventually goes crazy like how
we saw in episode one Rowan convinces
Agatha to let him see thell and she
agrees he even comes bearing gifts a
white rabbit the same name of the probe
that was sent to the vole Crenn
meanwhile sucuk is haunted by the ghost
of Dobrin as the red eye watches him
he's not handling it well Carl continues
his talks with his wife who tells him
she'll need to erase more of her
memories in order for her therapy to
work and Carl doesn't really like this
either
Rowan tries to get failed to communicate
with the bunny who he's affectionately
called Ralphy
after all if they'll is gonna
communicate with the volcker and he'll
need some practice and why not start
with something easy like a rabbit Dale
isn't too pleased with the task but when
Rowan's about to take the bunny away he
decides to give it a shot
Mel tells Carl that she wasn't able to
get anything from Arras and lomi is able
to figure out that someone has
compromised one of the engines thrusters
so much so that it would slow down their
speed to the vole Crenn and leave them
off course but before all the files are
deleted they're able to track where the
command came from heiresses quarters
Carl confronts Eris about this who says
he's aware of the problem and the night
flyer has been adjusting their course
accordingly but in order to fix the
thruster manually they need someone to
endure the harsh radiation it emits and
who's been genetically built for this
mell of course Rowan continues testing
fail but it's not exactly going as
planned when they're interrupted by Carl
he explains to Rowan his plan to break
into Eris's office to confront the real
heiress but in order to do so they'll
need some of his DNA that'll be easy to
find so they do the only logical thing
and drill a hole into a poop pipe Agatha
shows us this delightful drawing failed
rue about what Ralphie was thinking and
he laments about how no one on the ship
is getting home at least we know in
Agatha's case that's likely true and
Suzette continues to delve further into
madness Carl and Rowan gain access to
Eris's quarters by smearing the human
waste on the biometric scanner
wealth a land Agatha question Ralphie's
sudden demise finding that it was a
tapeworm fail was hearing not the rabbit
Eris and Mel ventured to fix thruster
for when Eris's projection is overtaken
by the red scanner she doesn't make it
in time and starts to experience
hallucinations first of lomi then an
older version of her sucuk storms the
command deck and demands they be taken
back to Europa Europa moon of Jupiter
which we saw them pass by last episode
he refers to the ship as her not wanting
them to go out to the Vulcan lomi visits
mal who's recovering from a radiation
exposure Eris for the first time wearing
something other than his captain outfit
tries to quell sucuk while Mel explains
the person who saved her was the real
captain Eris back on the bridge Eris
surprises everyone by karate-chopping
sucuk in the throat and breaking his
neck proving that he is indeed real he
proclaims to everyone that thanks to mal
they've regained control of thruster 4
and basically tells everyone to get back
to work after he just killed a man
Rowan and Carl venture further into
heiresses cabin passing by a bunch of
stained-glass windows like you'd find in
a church but notice these weird symbols
on the side which may come back later of
note as the painting of Cynthia Eris Roy
heiresses mother who he mentioned in
episode 2 and is it just me or does she
have a resemblance to Mel could that
have something to do with Ayers his
fascination with her carl surmises that
no one has been in that cabin for years
you can tell by the huge amount of dust
buildup but if that's true where's the
real Captain era spin the whole time
even weirder is the glass eye Rowan
finds in this Russian doll I guarantee
that'll be coming back later a
projection of Carl's wife appears who
Rowan can also see she chastises Carl
for not doing enough for their daughter
even when he knew his second wave of
Celia was on its way see Leo the disease
we briefly heard mention in episode 1
now we know that's how their daughter
died harris interrupts and the
projection vanishes when carl demands
answers cynthia uploaded her
consciousness to the night flyer and
she's the one that's been trying to kill
them why we still don't exactly know and
that's it for episode 3 of night fliers
I hope you'll stay with me as we
continue to explore the mysteries of
this show would love if you gave the
video a like and make sure to subscribe
with the Belon to know as soon as one of
my videos drops until next time remember
daddy loves you very much